there's one question all of Westminster
is asking how long can the Prime
Minister last behind this door the
cabinet discussed spending cuts that
less than a week ago the PM said
wouldn't happen after two hours a mass
walkout of sorts does the cabinet want
Liz trust to stay in post
Grim faces but safety in the pack did
the cabinet back Liz trust guys does the
cabinet want Liz trust to stay and Marie
trevelyn
nobody's saying that they want Liz trust
to stay what is that
the chancellor says decisions on Cuts
will be eye-watering the problem for the
prime minister is getting any ministers
to agree with them does the government
still support the three percent lift of
GDP on defense spending by 2030. yes and
Mr what your your colleague the
secretary of state says he would quit if
that would change would you join him
yeah
you would quit
yeah this threat prompted number 10 to
back down on defense Cuts but the PM
spokesman confirming today the pensions
triple lock is now under threat that
Department's Minister staying loyal for
now and blaming Global factors the Prime
Minister and the chancellor are looking
very very carefully at what is in the
National interest and that is what the
new chancellor has explained I think
quite well to the House of Commons and
publicly this week already and he's had
to say that all these decisions are on
the table because actually Global
conditions have worsened there are many
Tories who want her gone including the
very people that put her there the Tory
membership in a new poll more than half
of them want Liz truss to resign eight
out of ten think she's doing a bad job
and they want Boris Johnson to return to
succeed her and that is why some Tory
MPS think the membership shouldn't be
given the choice at all I I think it
would be an abdication of responsibility
and the electorate would crucify us
if we were to think that we had the
luxury of two weeks parliamentary
process
and then six or seven weeks of traveling
around in the country in sharabangs
talking to Federal conservatives in
Village halls and the like about the
merits of two candidates if there is to
be that event happening and as I say
there's still an if over it I think it's
got to be done quickly not just about
the process MPS can't agree on the
person who might replace Liz trust
either Mr sunax should the Prime
Minister resign
things used to go now
rejected by members once before could
this man be the next cab off the rank
Sam coat Sky News Westminster